À l'heure où la France rural et agricole s'est levée,
à l'heure où celle-ci dite à l'Europe entière sa
volonté de ne pas disparaître,
j'aimerais que nous pensions avant tout autre chose
ce soir, à nos agriculteurs,
à nos éleveurs,
à nos pêcheurs
mobilisés
partout en France pour la plus essentielle des libertés,
celle de pouvoir vivre de son travail.
Nous pouvons être fier
d'être à leur côté,
nous pouvons être fier d'être cette force
politique qui fonde son ADN dans La Défense
de l'identité
et de la souveraineté française.
Ayez conscience
que ce cri de révolte de ceux qui nous nourrissent
et le cri d'une France qui ne veut pas mourir.
L'agriculture française a forgé la puissance française,
elle a façonné nos paysages,
nos terroirs et dessiner notre hexagone.
Elle est le cœur battant de la ruralité,
de notre ruralité.
Elle est 1 part inestimable de notre identité
et de notre art de vivre.